ciao ragazzi benvenuti a prima edizione
di cucina buttata summer edition questa
è la nostra cucina
abbiamo un gonfiabile il nostro
scatolone fabbricone gonfiatore infine
abbiamo lui che ci saluta per questa
piccola finestrella dobbiamo ancora
tornargli un nome ma so già che loiero
perché sta proprio sul piano di lavoro
siamo pronti per questa giornata ragazzi
siamo pronti per festeggiare
quest'estate in maniera positiva
[Musica]
oggi facciamo l'anguriata un drink
estivo alcolico potreste farlo anche
analcolico aggiungendoci la frutta al
posto dell'alcol per almeno fermo
alcolico ed è a base fondamentalmente di
prosecco bocca e un sacco di frutta
tutta quanta servita all'interno di una
meta tecnica quindi fa anche figo
insomma da bere sia ormai quasi
instagram abili alle quali in realtà la
maggior fetta i presenti si attacca per
dimenticare i propri errori nobel e
responsabilmente per fare l'anguriata
avremo bisogno di innanzitutto una
cofana di frutta tra cui mezzo ananas o
un grappolo d'uva 3 pesche e nettarine
non lo so fare una vera due pere
albicocche
continua non saperlo fare un kiwi o
un'arancia un limone
una incuria da dodici chili di troppo
così oltre a frutta avremo bisogno di 30
grammi di zucchero 300 millilitri di
vodka 300 di acqua tonica e 750 di
prosecco partiamo è il momento per prima
cosa bisogna prendere un'anguria che
stia in piedi da sola per dire che
alcune ma tu sei andato supermercato
birther nel caso mette mente dire un
arsenale metti a quel pezzo che hai
tolto bravo certi è che devo dire niente
che ammazzi quel mercato lo storico di
pierino a questo punto dividiamo
l'anguria a metà la cosa importante
dividerla vita alta in modo che la meta
che ti rimane in piedi possa accogliere
più succo gradisse una motosega questa
regista ad un grande chirurgo commedia
per il mio nome ma un grande rilievo
tutto quanto l'interno cercavano proprio
di creare una ciotola e neppure posso
dire divertente facilissimo da fare
questo lo vedremo alla fine è noto
social dovevamo addio giammarco eccoti
a una cosa importantissima volevamo
ringraziare il blog e ricette dal mondo
che è quello nel quale stiamo copiando
questa ricetta in realtà aggiungerò
delle piccole modifiche ma di base
grazie ragazzi se sarebbe buona sarà
assolutamente campo
è molto simile al momento in cui fai la
zucca la halloween
solo che è bagnatissimo questo
pennarello indelebile contestato amanda
è cambiare ha fatto alla fine dovreste
trovarvi più o meno un qualcosa di così
vedete questo suono si sentono
differenza molto eccolo voi che avete
fatto bene prendiamo le tre pesche e le
tagliamo padelli è che capo ogni volta
che tra della frutta col coltello penso
sempre mia nonna perché mia nonna mangia
sindaco on.le bambina la frutta col
coltello e forchetta mentre mesi io
faccio prendere questo amici la voleva
che non è una da pesca unci pesca frutto
più come il mondo siamo albicocca il
manduria anguria modi oppure sono
abbastanza team pesca come andare qua
sotto facendoci sapere ma nel vostro
frutto preferito non può essere aprirà
ragazzi parlando dell'inutilità di per
sé vediamo le piere plugin a favore
frattempo prendi di limone e dvd una
meta esprimino contento velocità ma
falliscono
eccoci qua chiti annerisce per le molle
ma smettiamo di tagliare tenere li
passiamo al prossimo frutto cioè non c'è
più il giorno della gola linea dargli
supporto che di una lentezza anche di
arma da taglio sei albi occhino pack mi
sta mettendo fretta scuse né all'interno
del mio stesso canale attualmente questo
qui un video solo il taglio di fumare
ll para petizione al dopodomani con
tutto questo può come ea che è più bella
dopo i passi guglielmo amica maria ti
prego la linea fermalo
insomma guarda l'anarchico che taglia
lunga come rivelatore schiumando 15
ragazzi vedere questo succoso tutto da
dentro un bicchierino potremmo fa
collaborino e vero finalmente una
trattata presidente anguria ma c'è gente
veramente togli semi 1 a 1 e io di base
dello simile a mente mastichi col palato
e conto coi denti e un altro al palato
la maschili ma è come mai sei del taro
lusi molto i denti ma ragazzi abbiamo
tutta la nostra frutta io so già che qua
sotto mi distrugge rete con perché non è
tolto i semi benissimo era troppa
abbiamo vinto le ciotole e quindi
useremo la coscia di quest'anno e ascom
e ciotola di monet
ma come si fa a premere un arancia senza
straniera
a questo punto nel nostro shaker
versiamo lo zucchero sala a cosa
prendiamo ragazzo sente stato inizio
abbiamo visto
la bocca o meno della metà e cosa che ci
devono
mamma mia è 4 giocato la mano pesante
non saranno più o meno così presto
quindi la rifacciamo no no no questa va
benissimo nella morte in guardia
bellissime sono troppo intelligenti con
del creativo si dà il metodo boldi che
proprio tutto finito
[Musica]
la capacità che bella d'ora dalla fine
ecco ma regala ben riuscito gianmarco
ecco perché si burla posso partire
subito dicendo una cosa fa a bellissimi
ragazzi tra l'altro anche abbastanza
versatile metterci per un pratico
cappellino in un aspetto estivo bell
aspetto però dico che in realtà
l'aspetto non è neanche troppo medico di
guglielmo questa era mela si aspetta di
do otto e mezzo bellissima ma perché è
un affare meglio sulla stessa base 9
meno essa è la bella anguria fatto i
denti quindi bel 9 pieno è un periodo in
quest'anno generosissima non capiterà
mai più diciamo sette e mezzo io do non
ho visto poi chissà che grande estro
scusa e guglielmo non hanno mantello
l'odore trecate no a seconda di dove
giustamente odori prevale o un pochino
lana sotto di noi pure penta qua solo
ananas e qua solo amore è che vuol dire
che potremmo aver fatto un buon lavoro
quindi temperato l'alcol che magari è un
po strong è vero questo sa più dialogo
su questo sa più di anguria preferisco
questo mi aspettavo un odore più
pungente di frutta da 8
77 e mezzo lo stesso si scusate il
cambio
ma roba intensa androne da bucanieri
questa è buono però tosto forse
compromesso del convento marino questo
mi piace di più cioè questo un conto in
12 sor sine die già cinque o sei le
aspettava qualcosa di a livello di
sapore più fresco perché c'è questa
nuova alcolica che lo rende veramente
cento si sta oltre a tutti gli
ingredienti che ci abbiamo messo pure il
sudore della mia fronte sbaglio quello e
mezzo il pezzo è così strettamente
marinara vari tipi di fuori il capitano
e poi rimane adesso ha fatto talmente
tante volte l'ha fatto che secondo
mettere un po di partite non lo so mi ha
messo comunque a gioved proporrò io lo
trovo buonissimo ragan lo farei un po
meno strong devo essere sincera
nonostante gli hopi la cavi abbastanza
bene con i drink sapore darei un 7 cioè
per mezzo dai sette e mezzo perché se
invece della vodka ci fosse stato il
gene permetterebbe stato un 9 pieno io
non sono minimamente un fan di coppia
quanto pagherei per questo link
questo forse a ma quando tra un pochino
per farti una sola 14 euro 8 euro per
questo che più una monoporzione 10 euro
da 12 14 euro a questo sono me anche a
20 euro lo vuoi mettere senza problemi è
una cofana comunque carichino grazie
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questa prima puntata della nostra summer
edition di cucina buttata spero che vi
sia piaciuta metteteci un like sedi
diverte e fateci sapere che cosa stai
in questo periodo estivo se state
divertendo se ancora siete partiti se
avete intenzione di partire questo
youtube continueremo a uscire giovedì e
domenica ancora saprà cosa metteremo
qualche contenuto un pochino così
speciale però per il momento questa sarà
programmazione altra cosa se prende
sapere che cosa stiamo facendo in questo
preciso momento potrete sempre con un
salto sino a si instagram che
continueremo ad aggiornare durante tutta
questa una vacanza un bacio grande ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao
bol
questa merita hanno aiutato dal sapore
73 di cavallaro hunter valley ti
dobbiamo tutto bello il 17 dicembre